dans votre livre Eric Zemmour depuis
l'apparition du lit d'ailleurs une des
choses dont on parle le plus c'est votre
relation avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon tu as
eu l'occasion de voir tous les deux vous
avez fait un débat vous en avez fait
deux même avec moi chez moi ici et
tu connais Jean-Luc Mélenchon depuis des
années il était alors membre du Parti
socialiste et moi journaliste nos
origines communes de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée et même un goût pour
l'histoire nous ont rapproché je crois
pouvoir dire que nous étions ce qu'on
appelle de bons copains il était là
lorsque j'ai fêté mes 50 ans et nous
nous tenions dans une estime réciproque
qui lui fit dire un jour à la télévision
je connais très bien Éric Zemmour ce
n'est pas un raciste il est vrai c'est
un brillant intellectuel on a l'extrait
quand il le dit regardez connaissez-vous
il ferait mieux de dire qu'il a dit une
bêtise ce type n'est pas un raciste est
un c'est un brillant intellectuel mais
il est comme tous les intellectuels têtu
comme une mule ce qu'il a dit et comme
il l'a dit n'est pas bien dit voilà
c'est tout ce qu'il faut qu'ils disent
maintenant alors on apprend aussi qu'il
était bien content que vous vous
présentiez que vous vous parliez encore
même si le candidat de la France
insoumise est complètement parano ce que
vous dites c'est toi qui s'assoit à
temps on parle pas ici appelle-moi à cet
autre numéro sur telegram Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est prudent plus encore il est
méfiant suspicieux les jeunes diraient
qu'il est parano je ne peux m'empêcher
de songer à Staline qui disait-on
changer d'appartement chaque soir il a
reconnu ma voix comme j'ai reconnu la
sienne mais il préfère prendre des
précautions puis au fil des appels qui
se multiplient il se livrera davantage
avec quand vous vous appelez il était en
stress les premières fois c'est ça alors
pour venir aussi sur le grand débat que
vous avez vécu sur BFM TV j'ai souhaité
le contacter en ce mois de septembre
radieux pour lui faire une proposition
qui ne pourra pas refuser il veut
devenir le patron des gauches cela tombe
bien je veux faire l'union des électeurs
de droite je pressens qu'un débat l'un
contre l'autre peut nous permettre de
rameuter nos camps respectifs et de
montrer à la France que le clivage
droite-gauche est plus que jamais actuel
je n'ai pas besoin de lui expliquer
l'intérêt ce débat longtemps il comprend
il sait déjà et accepte rapidement
donc ça c'était ce fameux débat sur BFM
c'était le 23 septembre 2021 c'était le
jour de mon anniversaire est-ce que vous
avez fait ça pour moi
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon il vous attaque
direct ce jour-là dès la première
question des journaliste là donc
Mélenchon a répondu il dit que il a dit
qu'il n'était pas l'ami d'Éric Zemmour
qu'il détestait ce que vous racontiez et
cependant rapidement plusieurs
personnalités politiques ont réagi sur
les réseaux sociaux ils accusent de
Mélenchon de menteurs Jean-Luc Mélenchon
moi comme il respire Éric Naulleau qui
dit ça je les connaissances des messages
amicaux et même fraternels qu'il a
adressait eczéma pour le conseiller sur
sa campagne présidentielle il renie son
amitié envers lui comme il l'avait fait
envers Cyril Hanouna je peux en
témoigner moi-même si faoui Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ment lorsqu'on septembre 2010
je publie un livre pour dénoncer le
discours d'Éric Zemmour Mélenchon que je
croisais dans un meeting organisé par
SOS racines m'interpeller pour me dire
ne t'attaque pas Zemmour c'est mon ami
et d'autres voilà
Eric Éric Zemmour je suis dans un café
début de campagne sur son téléphone
s'affiche le nom de JLM qu'il appelle
Eric répond et par trois mètres plus
loin je le vois rire pendant 10 minutes
la conversation est très détendue
Jean-Luc Mélenchon assumer c'est pas
grave
alors
les témoignages vous avez tous compris
mais essayons d'aller plus au fond oui
c'était un ami je parle d'une époque
quand même mis à 10 ans mais bon on a le
droit de changer moi quand j'ai connu
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
on était on avait des points d'accord
c'était l'époque où il estimait que on
pouvait critiquer l'islam ouistimait
qu'il était pour le nucléaire aussi on
estimait aussi il se moquait des femmes
voilées il disait qu'elle s'auto
stigmatisées il a changé en vérité comme
la gauche et Jean-Luc Mélenchon ont
perdu les classes populaires ils se sont
trouvés et ils se sont cherchés et
trouvés d'ailleurs un électorat de
substitution et l'électorat de
substitution ce sont les musulmans qui
ont voté à 69% pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est ce qui a fait ces gros scores dans
toutes les banlieues et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui il défilent contre
l'islamophobie et il m'accuse d'être de
pousser à la guerre etc etc moi je vais
vous dire il est moi aussi je déteste
qu'il est devenu parce que j'estime que
c'est lui qui a aujourd'hui forgé ce
peuple islamo gauchiste parce que qui a
voté pour lui les musulmans et les
gauchistes c'est pas grave il est
comment c'est pas
c'est que il leur donne c'est les
Français qui ont voté une existence
politique non mais attendez moi je
connais des citoyens français qui soit
de n'importe quelle religion on est
d'accord donc on est français avant
évidemment mais sauf que tous les
sondages prouve et toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion pauvres que ils ont voté quel
que soit leur position politique ou sur
l'économie etc même si c'était pas
d'accord avec Mélenchon sur l'économie
pour des raisons justement
communautaires c'est ça qui est grave et
il a tout fait pour ça et il a réussi
donc si vous voulez moi j'estime que
c'est Mélenchon qui est dangereux pour
la France il est passé de l'amitié à
Zemmour à être
l'ennemi de la France et il s'en moque
il fait ça avec un cynisme absolu donc
si vous voulez oui moi aussi je pense je
déteste que dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'il est
dangereux pour la France mais il s'en
moque vous comprenez
il est après moi le déluge il sait
exactement ce qu'il fait mais il se
moque complètement des conséquences à
long terme c'est ce que je répondais à
Madame tout à l'heure moi j'essaye de
voir les conséquences à long terme à 10
ans à 20 ans lui sans moque alors on a
des questions pour en quoi le rebondis
sur ce que vous venez je vous en prie
dire en quoi le vote musulman selon vous
semble être un problème peu importe que
les musulmans est votaient les Français
qui votent et s'expriment comme tant
d'autres tout à fait soit catholique
juif tout à fait bouddhiste
et
tout à fait vous avez tout à fait raison
attendez attendez c'est pas un problème
en soi évidemment c'est pas ce que j'ai
voulu dire ce que ça devient un problème
c'est toujours la même chose ça devient
un problème quand c'est un effet de
masse quand vous avez
70%, 75 % de gens de la même confession
qui votent pour un seul candidat ça
prouve qu'il y a un effet de et qui a un
effet si vous voulez communautaire quand
il y a un vote juif par exemple on parle
beaucoup de juif ou un vote
musulmanes cher madame
c'est les déclaration c'est déclaratifs
on le sait on le sait pour qui les Juifs
votes on le sait pour qui les catholique
vote on sait pour qui les
musulman en l'occurrence il y a eu mais
il y a pas toujours je dis pas qu'il y a
toujours là je dis qu'il a tout fait
pour et il y a eu Messi d'ailleurs les
enquêtes pardonnez-moi monsieur Verdez
les enquêtes d'opinion le disent les
gens l'expriment on a voté pour lui car
il luttait contre l'islamophobie on a
lutté pour lui on peut pas pour les
autres musulman de ne pas voter pour
Marine Le Pen au Congo mais non mais
attends forcément après il reste tout
Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui non mais
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai il y avait
il y avait Anne Hidalgo il y avait
Yannick jadou il y avait Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que vous savez
est-ce que vous avez que les Frères
musulmans les Frères musulmans là les
mosquées la Mosquée de Paris ont donné
des consignes pour qu'on vote Mélenchon
et au second tour
mais moi je suis désolé
pour les voter pour moi ah bah vous êtes
sûrs
je vais vous raconter une anecdote ah si
vous me permettez j'en ai pour 2 minutes
je marchais dans les rues et j'ai une
dame avec sa fille une dame de ma
génération avec sa fille qui devait
avoir 25-30 ans qui m'arrête et qui me
disent ce qu'on peut vous parler une
minute et tu rajoutes mais sur Madame et
voilà et la mère me dit je tiens à vous
dire madame monsieur je suis
musulmane ça fait 40 ans que je vis en
France vous avez tout à fait raison la
religion c'est dans le privé on n'a pas
à s'afficher on n'a pas avoir une fille
voilée dans la rue on n'a pas à montrer
sa religion dans la rue c'est vous qui
avez raison et on a voté pour vous et on
a appris des photos évidemment comme on
fait maintenant rituellement mais c'est
pour vous dire que il y a des musulmans
qui ont vécu la France des années 60-70
qui ont très bien connu cette France
authentiquement républicaine pour le
coup contrairement à ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire la France de
assimilation et de la discrétion des
religions moi je vais vous dire je suis
de confession juive quand j'étais petit
qu'on allait à la synagogue on mettait
la calotte sur la tête on disait galant
ça va vous amuser je fais toujours cette
réflexion là on disait calotte en
français et non pas qui pas comme
aujourd'hui voyez ce que ça veut dire
les mots ont une importance et ma mère
dès qu'on sortait de la synagogue elle
m'attrapait comme ça je la revois la
peau elle m'attrapait elle me disait tu
m'enlèves ta calotte tout de suite mais
le monde a changé mais il change en mal
la France c'est l'assimilation c'est le
fait que on ne doit pas montrer je vais
vous dire pourquoi pour ne pas choquer
les gens qui ne sont pas de cette année
pas dérangeante
ça ne devrait pas vous déranger je ne
l'était pas si vous voulez le principe
même de la de la République et de la
laïcité à la française c'est que
l'espace public est absolument neutre et
que les gens peuvent s'y balader sans se
poser la question de savoir si Madame
croit en Dieu ou pas ou si vous vous
êtes de religion bouddhiste ou n'importe
quoi